if I could just tag on to what you were  saying a couple days ago you had the  crash and steam Brothers on and they  said something that bothered me uh  everything they say about it no no  something that I kind of like it really  stuck with me they said uh they don't  like that Republican legislature is uh  making laws against or focusing too much  on culture I'm probably paraphrasing it  wrong they said they shouldn't they care  too much about social issues correct  yeah that's what they said they I mean I  think that that you guys are completely  over the target if you have pinpointed  an issue in this Society a linchpin that  is well I mean it's holding them  together but you you guys are right over  it and when the left sees that or  whoever it may be when they see that  they kind of start to get frazzled and  they said it out loud which to me was  like kind of amazing but I've I've heard  it before multiple times where you're  calling someone out that's what they're  doing in